After Ant Man, asked the question: "You ever watch Iron Man? But small?"
Marvel's latest solo movie invites you to ask another:
"You ever watch Iron Man, on weed?"
DOCTOR STRANGE
Experience the grand illusion (that you haven't seen this movie before), as you sit through the heroic origins of
a cocky but capable, super rich, wise-cracking, workaholic with a weird goatee,
in-love with a red-headed subordinate, learning to be less selfish, played by a famous Sherlock Holmes actor.
Its like Iron Man! But, actually that's it. Its pretty much JUST like Iron Man.
Magic has come to the Marvel universe, and not that it's just science b.s. that Thor went on about.
"Your ancestors called it magic, and you call it science."
We're talking acid trips, 70's blacklight  poster magic that bends space and time in new plot-breaking ways.
And uses mind-blowing effects to distract you from the fact that the action is still 90% punching
Umm... shouldn't that hurt his hands?
You cringed when he tried to do a Southern accent
"The power d-d-didn't go out... u-uh I forgot to set the clock... u-uh I'm sorry mom"
You weren't sure if he was serious when he attempted a Boston one
"You know what John.. Good to see you doing so well."
Now, Benedict Cumberbatch will sound like an English man, pretending to be a German man, pretending to be an American
In a featured length tribute to Hans Gruber's accent in Die Hard when he gets caught by Bruce Willis.
"Please God, no you're one of them aren't you?"
"You care so much! Don't you?"
Benny, Bobby. Your natural voice is perfect, use it.
Joining the titular strange on his journey from Act 1 protagonist, to Act 3 protagonist.
Are side characters and villains (who are up to the usual Marvel standard).
Chiwetel Ejiofor, who's just kind of there to explain things.
"Temporal manipulations can create branches in time."
"This is a relic. The sanctums protect the world, and we sorcerers protect the sanctums."
Mads Mikkelsen, playing a bad guy with weird eyes, for the third time in his career.
Who's entire plan revolves around successfully ripping some pages out of a book,
To summon a malevolent demon who he hopes will enslave the human race.
"Not a great plan."
Tilda Swinton, a being of immense power.
Bravely guarding the marvel cinematic universe from Asian actors.
"She's Celtic"
And this cloak with more personality than any of the human beings.
Ah-waghh *thud*
"Stop"
Man, I want to see that cloak crossover with the rug in Aladdin so bad.
Enjoy a visual masterpiece that has to be seen in 3-D on a giant screen to be fully appreciated.
Because when you watch it on a laptop, you realize just how much of it is medical mumbo-jumbo.
"You need to get him
prepped for a suboccipital craniotomy."
"Look, I'm fusing transected
spinal cords, I'm
stimulating neurogenesis in
the central nervous system."
"Pass the stent down the
brachial artery into the radial artery."
"To complete C7-C8 spinal cord injury."
With a heaping side order of magic mumbo-jumbo.
"The Dark Dimension makes
them more powerful in
the Mirror Dimension."
"I saw the rituals in
the book of Cagliostro."
"I pushed
your astral form out of your physical form."
"The Wand of Watoomb."
"The Vaulting Boots of Valtorr."
"The pages that Kaecilius stole."
"A ritual to contact Dormammu and
draw power from the Dark Dimension."
Winguardian Levios-suck me sideways this is unnecessary.
Just shoot laser beams out of your wand and be done with it.
So enjoy a film that despite it's faults,
doesn't fall into the third act trap
of battling a CGI army and a sky beam.
Saves money by playing the same scene thirteen times in a row.
"Dormammu! I've come to bargain."
And sends a powerful message to the children.
Modern medicine can't be trusted.
"My spirit deepened, and somehow..."
"- Your body healed."
"- Yes."
And don't text and drive.
*tires screech, crash*
Because you might end up turning into a wizard.
"I'm not sure what to do with my hands" - Ricky Bobby
So Cumberbatch did the motion capture for Dormammu himself.
Man, he really likes to goof around in leotards huh.
"Nonnnne, can stop me!"
*pants*
*hisses*
Hey screen junkies, Hollywood's hottest daughter isn't done with you yet.
Click the box on the left to watch Benedict Cumberbatch
Answer our silly questions in our honest interview
Or, click the box on the right to see where our Cumber crush began
In the honest trailer for Sherlock
And please stop yelling at us about aluminum.
We get it.
"Dormammu I've come to bargain."
*repeats for about 5 times*